if we are trying to sort of drive a new
Industrial Revolution here as it's often
described and
how do we make that more Equitable
across the UK I mean the the government
previous governments as well have looked
at clusters at catapults at places where
we can accelerate and provide
opportunities for companies are those
working could we do it better
I mean the answer is if you look across
the UK there are areas of great strength
distribution widely across the country
you look across Southern Scotland
there's incredible Quantum Technologies
photonics Quantum Technologies yeah
Quantum Quantum Computing and yeah and
satellite industry as well you look in
the Midlands there's the Warwick the
advanced manufacturing center there are
real areas of strength um uh renewable
energy Northeast for example so when you
draw the map you do actually see why
they distribute strengths I think the
mistake is to think that you can
suddenly dump as it were a
nanotechnology Institute in any part of
the country what you have to do is build
on strengths and we've got great
universities very widely distributed
they all have enormous areas of strength
and the best universities have areas of
weakness as well so I think the trick is
not as it were just to try and create
something out of the blue because that's
very difficult but to work out where the
areas of strengths are and build up you
know Manchester a great University lots
of strengths it's where
um
I think carbon graphene wouldn't come
out you're right
just examples like that we just have to
build on them wherever they are there's
a tendency to say what you need here are
clusters and then to approach that in a
very sort of artificial way but what is
really at the heart of a cluster why
does a cluster work because it's a
network it's a network of people who
have some level of commonality or
insight into what each other are doing
and so forth and if you look at almost
anything that's been successful in this
country or anywhere else over a long
period two things tend to emerge right
very strong networks of stakeholders who
manage to work together across various
different organizational divides and
then kind of long-term commitment to
whatever it is that they're trying to
achieve and I think in this country we
can do better on both on the first we
can do better at ensuring that the right
people are connected across the country
um if you look at the way that we
support most Innovation we do it through
r d tax credits and r d tax credits um
are both an incredibly effective means
but also quite an obscure one you don't
really know who's been given an r d tax
credit you might want to collaborate
with them can't quite find that out so
there are other things you can do in
order to make it easier for people to
network work within or across
geographical clusters and then there's
this long-terminism which we haven't
touched upon
um the commander of the 82nd Airborne a
very famous U.S uh military unit once
told me that the most important thing
for anything he did was
stick-to-itiveness
intuitiveness and I like that and I
think we need to stick to it of this in
this country if we want to achieve
things